[Music]
okay everyone i'm
really really amped today because i have
the honor of talking to kingsley ben
adir aka malcolm x
kingsley how you doing today man yo
what's up steve
um so everyone who's watching this
interview right now just a heads up
we're going to be talking spoilers in
this film of one night in miami
so make sure you tune in after you watch
the film so
having said that kingsley this morning i
woke up
i was i'm a guy i like to gamble and i
look up like vegas predictions and odds
and
i saw that you are right now one of the
favorites to be nominated for lead actor
for the oscars
how does that make you feel as an actor
seeing something like that
i don't i don't i don't know that so
yeah i'm hearing this for the first time
from you
and i guess feeling was
in real time kind of surreal
and uh honored but mainly surreal i
guess
yeah i mean i i saw it i was like wow
like i have those top fives that get
nominated you're right now a favorite
and
i think it's so well deserved and it's
interesting too because
with your approach to malcolm x here i
feel like you brought so much humanity
to
a character of malcolm x and i think
that was much needed because i think he
gets misjudged a lot in the public
eye through history and i wonder was
that
conscious on your part or is that
something that kind of just came about
absolutely conscious and it was crucial
it was crucial it was the first thing i
really
responded to when i read the piece
i was reading it for cash and i kept
being drawn towards malcolm
and i guess what i was experiencing was
this really
interesting take on the vulnerability of
of him and all of all of the men but
particularly like malcolm for me maybe
because i was just
drawn towards him this was like no this
is an opportunity to like
show a really different side of the
great man you know
yeah i think you did a hell of a job on
that department of it it was so needed
for people to see
now you're you're such a talent at just
commanding the screen but what i notice
is like you can tell that you're a
really
trained actor that you you're this isn't
your first rodeo so knowing that you've
actually worked in
theater i wonder i was watching i'm like
how is
the amount of dialogue you have to pull
off in the second act and blocking was
that
like one of the most challenging things
you had to do on a set like compared to
like theater work and
you know how much did the theater work
kind of prepare you for a role like this
i mean i i had i had a very short amount
of time over christmas to prepare
i had like 12 12 or 13 days and i was
like
i have to show up on day one
and not be thinking about my lines you
know depending on the role
i'm sort of 50 50 with land learning
like some sometimes there's
there's something to be something
fluid there's something fluid about not
knowing your lines sometimes
like i remember on high fidelity i made
a point of not learning my lines until
the day
because so much of it was about
responding to zoe and just being
emotionally available and they were only
like one lines at a time
but with this was the opposite i was
like i need to really get
off the book so i i had someone come
around to my house
every morning his name is andy buzzio
and he'd look for me at like eight
and we ran the film we've ran the film
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
times so when i got the first day
in new orleans and with regina and the
and the guys
and we did off table read i didn't need
a script you know i just was
i could just i just fired the whole
performance off the table because
regina and i spoke about over christmas
needing to be able to jump in and out of
any moment of the film at any time just
because of structurally how
the schedule was going to work so that
was my
you know commitment to malcolm but
commitment to regina in the production
as well just to make sure i was on top
of that
so that's interesting you mentioned
regina so regina king people don't know
amazing actress directing this film it's
her feature directorial debut
can you kind of give me the pros of
working with a director that is an
actress an experienced actress like
herself like maybe some things you
noticed from this
particular experience you would kind of
take with you for your other projects
regina regina was everything about this
project
she she her understanding
her deep connection to the craft of
acting and
process and her sensitivity around
emotional performance
she really guided us man like i i look
back and i'm like
wha uh just like just
that i worked with her you know like it
was a really
really really really special few months
yeah i mean and i i could see like you
guys
give that vibe like everyone there is
giving 150
you know and some films you don't feel
that and this you clearly do
and i think what you did so well with
malcolm x is you see
like different emotions just you present
just through your facial expressions
whether it's paranoia
or just always very serious but also
like is the realist of this group
do you though find because i feel like
maybe the only joy this man maybe ever
feels is like when he's on the phone
with his daughter like do you find much
joy in this man like when you got into
his head like
what is your kind of view on that i
think his cameras in this movie with
that i wanted to make them his
a treasure for him okay in the moments
you know the moments with with with his
girl on the phone
regina and i spoke about being very very
careful about we wanted to find as much
smiling as we could because we knew when
we got into the room
after the roof that the movie was going
to go into a really
heavy feeling and and the direction was
going to
you know the night was just steering off
track so in that beginning being at the
fight and with the prayer and at the
phone box and with the boys in the room
it was really about trying to find as
many moments as we could
grounded in you know the psychology and
and in malcolm's point of view but
just to see him smile because he smiled
so much you know
the archive footage can be really
deceptive if you if you spend as much
time as
i did with malcolm watching him i mean
he beamed
he beamed and he was a funny man like he
was
very very funny good humid sweet and
kind and bashful and
you know a really modest guy and and
there's a misconception you know for for
many people that martin luther king was
the goody and
malcolm was the baddie and and this was
really an opportunity to like
show a side of malcolm to kind of get
rid of that stupid notion
he was so much more than
you know what the the the stereotype can
feel like it is sometimes
yeah and i mean the film totally pulls
that off too
and just wrapping this up with you
kingsley the last thing i want to talk
about
philosophy about this movie is what do
you think the main thing this film is
trying to say what is it trying to speak
to this audience
i don't know but i hope that people get
to the end
and are thinking about some of the
questions that are raised i think if
that
that's happening then we've done our job
you know the the yeah
the conversation between malcolm and sam
about
what it means to be uh a responsible
black celebrity to be to use your voice
to use your platform to
like to just to just to question what
that means
for all of us and for all of us it's
different depending on who you are and i
think if we
somehow managed to
spark or ignite
some conversation around that then i
hope that's what
you know that comes out kingsley that
was uh beautifully said
i'm excited for people if they've
already watched it or haven't
just keep watching this film it's gonna
be talked out so long now it's a
award buzz here uh it's one night miami
on amazon prime now you can watch it
kingsley thank you so much for joining
me and i wish you the best of luck i'll
be rooting for you in awards season
thank you steve